I think one of the things
that should be really made clear about
the opposition to self-id from from
feminists or people like me is that this
has never really been about trans people
exactly it's been about safeguarding
women and children so for me those are
the two priorities that we Safeguard
particularly gender non-conforming
teenagers particularly girls and that we
safeguards The Single Sex spaces so to
safeguard Single Sex spaces we do have
to have a clear definition of a
biological woman and I don't think labor
is set up I mean I think they're pushing
towards it
but I don't know how much they'd believe
it given so many of the things that
they've said given that they've let
somebody like Rosie Duffield be publicly
humiliated
week by week without stepping in I think
there's just a lot of distrust and I
think that if labor want to win back
women they have to prove they have a lot
to prove still